OK THAT’S ALL I GOT.
Oh that’s.
Yeah, that’s not even close.
Oh dammit...
Hey animals, you’ve found DNews, I’m Trace.
This video was everywhere recently showing
a dragonfish opening its jaws by 120 degrees
-- meaning they can, horrifyingly, swallow
their prey whole!
The gorgeous video is from a new study in
PLoS One looking at evolution of the heads
of this family of deep-sea fish.
The dragonfish has sharp teeth, not for chewing,
but for holding.
The idea is to get the food into the stomach
whole…
Yikes.
There’s not a lot of food where it lives,
so this is a huge advantage.
But, the ability to swallow food whole isn’t
unique to these fish.
In terms of jaw opening, the burmese python
puts the dragonfish to shame -- with jaws
opening to 150 degrees -- 180 is a straight
line.
The goal here is to, of course, swallow food
whole -- which just sounds… uncomfortable.
Why would an animal evolve to not chew?
Swallowing food whole evolved because, to
be honest… chewing is hard work; it takes
energy!
Most mammals chew -- though not all, dolphins
swallow their food whole.
Reptiles on the other hand, seem to like only
taking one bite.
This is because chewing expends energy.
A 2013 study in PLoS One postulates that a
major advantage for swallowing food whole
is [quote] “No time needed for processing.”
Animals that swallow food whole get the energy
from their food ASAP with minimal energy tax.
The Plos One researchers think not chewing
is what helped some dinosaurs grow so large!
In a study done with a python, 37 percent
of all the energy in the food was spent just
digesting it in the first place!
So, many animals swallow their food whole,
simply to get the energy as quickly as possible.
Circumventing this energy tax helped us evolve
too!
Ancient humans had large faces with bigger
chew muscles.
A 2016 Nature study found as we evolved tools,
we began slicing or grinding our food before
eating and that decreased chewing by 13 percent
-- more energy for doing other things (like
thinking)!
So, the dragonfish doesn’t chew likely because
it’s quicker to let the teeth grab, and
the fish swallow to get things started.
It costs less energy.
But, we had trouble finding a lot of information
on exactly how the dragonfish’s digestion
works.
Luckily, we have some analogs, on land, the
snake, for example!
Snakes swallow food whole, and have special
enzymes in their saliva to start the digestive
process as they “walk” their jaws over
the food to pull it into their stomach.
Snake venom contains cytotoxins -- which are
also for digestion.
They starts the process from the inside.
On top of that, once in the stomach the snake
has to digest everything (pretty much).
They have specialized cells shaped like golf
tees that help break down the hard bits, even
bones and eggshells -- depending on the species
of snake.
Because a giant bulge in the middle of one’s
body is evolutionarily disadvantageous, digestion
happens quickly; estimates range from a couple
days to several weeks.
So, back to the dragonfish: it has this crazy
jaw in part because it needs to swallow food
before the food can escape, plus it doesn’t
need to chew… because that costs energy.
If the prey is large, the dragonfish can expand
its stomach not unlike a snake!
But commonly, they’ll eat smaller things
like shrimp, plankton, other fish… or get
aggressive and snag the occasional cephalopod.
Hopefully, someday, we’ll know more about
this intriguing species but for now, at least,
we have this crazy jaw to look at.
Evolution is an incredible thing, creating
a whole tapestry of different forms of life,
but this one animal or plant… or… or animal.
Which is it?
It might be both…
Watch this video to see how something could
be both plant and animal.
What’s the most food you’ve eaten in one
bite.
I actually can eat a hot dog with condiments
and bun at once, but the chewing is ain’t
pretty...
Let us know down in the comments, make sure
subscribe for more DNews and thanks for watching.